we used to the idea of sex being used to
sell stuff
it happens all the time often it's used
to sell cars or perfumes or even less
substantial things like ice creams
making use of another human being
sexuality to generate an enthusiasm for
consumer products seems a pretty
depressing maneuver the meaning as much
to buyers and produces but before we
despair of our shallowness
let's go back a few centuries to
consider the educational theories of one
of the greatest Renaissance Italian
philosophers marsilio Latino latina was
unfazed by our tendencies to be
interested in sex
this was he thought simply an inevitable
consequence of our bodily nature which
dictate their initial interesting things
almost invariably spring from our sexual
and sensory faculties
now the reason for gina was undisturbed
by this is that this wasn't in his eyes
the end of the story there are
interesting things may well begin at the
sexual level
this is merely the starting point the
destiny of our interest is to move onto
a stage of higher engagement that for
chino call
enough
and from there we may ascend to a third
stage the longing and capacity to
understand
so our interests are naturally inclined
if well tended to follow a path from sex
to love to intellectual engagement and
this holds true for an interesting
people and virtues and even an abstract
ideas
patina was above all else and educator
that is he thought profoundly about how
people learn and how one can best teach
people and so he concluded that the best
way to get an idea into someone's mind
is not to try at once
coldly to engage their reason it is
first to reach them
fire their senses and in particular by
their interest in sex
Pacino was employed by the great
Renaissance patron and statesmen lorenzo
de medici both were desperate to educate
as many people as possible in Florence
to be wise and good using the lessons of
antiquity
and Christianity and they wanted to use
art to do this
launching what was in effect a giant ad
campaign for the highest goals
Pitino's ideas lent this educational
program unique angle
Pitino proposed that the artist Lorenzo
was employing should devote themselves
to painting successions of beautiful the
plan
sexy people we may have often been
struck by how many attractive people
there are in a sense that this is no
coincidence
it's a deliberate consequence of the
chinos educational theories artist
guided by the philosopher were
commissioned to use sex to sell but fell
the highest things like piety virtue and
modesty commitment to the intellect and
devotion to scholarship
it's a maneuver we've come to forget in
our own times we still use back but only
ever to sell the lowest thing and when
it comes to the highest things we
dealing above the grubby task of being
sold
and therefore the anguish with Pitino's
lessons in mind we should be more
strategic we should recognize that
there's nothing wrong with using sex to
film along with what we're selling
happens to be Noble
indeed selling higher things index is a
generous act the graciously
acknowledging how our minds really work
we cannot or should not be expected to
learn without our senses first having
been lit up
we just have to make sure we're doing
the right thing . card for confectionery
band in the channel devoted to wisdom
and philosophy
Aquino would have a preview
if you like all films take a look at our
shop
the school of life . com /a shop you'll
find lots of thoughtful books games
stationery and more